is JLo sending out a message following  her reported split from beau Casper  Smart  the angel mama singer shared this shot  on set of shades of blue but it's the  graffiti she's standing next to that  says it all protect your heart I know  for sure that you have to love yourself  first the telling message comes after  the 47 year old singer has apparently  called it quits with her longtime  boyfriend Casper the two exes reportedly  remained amicable we're great friends  you know I love her and the kids and  they're they're incredible earlier this  week Casper Instagram a post that red  going back to a time before social media  gonna focus on personal connections over  a type and text existence clearly JLo is  keeping her social game strong